who do you think in life has made the
least amount of mistakes watch this
question in life who's made the fewest
amount of dumb decisions in his life RFK
Trump Biden DeSantis
Pence who do you think is made the
fewest mistakes
that's the problem
that's the problem why is that a problem
what an interesting point you ever met
other than he's much younger dude no no
that's not it that's got nothing to do
with it RFK Vivek is super young it's
not it's not because Vivek I think it's
38 I don't know I think it's 38 or 39.
it's got nothing to do with age this has
got to do it who's made the fewest
mistakes as DeSantis do you know nobody
puts more pressure on the census than
himself I don't know the Dynamics of how
he was raised with Mom and Dad we all
like to keep a little bit of as a secret
you know even in the book Joseph Kennedy
I'm reading Joseph Kennedy doesn't want
to reveal a lot about his relationship
with his mom and dad he just doesn't
want to be because he wants to identify
as I made my own money he didn't want to
give that credit to his parents
when I watch the scientists I almost
feel like his entire life has been nope
I can't kiss that girl because people
are going to say this nope I can't punch
that guy in the face because they're
going to say this nope I can't do this
because this nope I can't say that
because of no I can't read this because
one day if I ever run and they find out
I wrote this paper my grudge and they're
going to say this I think he's that guy
and I think he needs to have a
one-on-one conversation with himself and
say listen man it's okay to make
mistakes bro all these candidates have
made more mistakes than you America
doesn't relate to Perfect People America
relates to Broken People America relates
to people who have made mistakes America
relates to people that are not perfect
he is too perfect did you happen to see
the video during covid when he actually
broke down crying when he was explaining
that they had locked down those people
and people didn't get to say goodbye to
their parents yes I think that's the
moment that you're looking for you're
looking for that sort of honesty it's
interesting because I'm with you on that
but but to another extent this this also
strikes me sort of like the marketing
thing we're holding something against
the guy like we're sort of saying he's
too functional in a way way and I I and
and that to me strikes me a bit as oh
he's accomplishing too many of the
things we want he's too functional he
does it he doesn't make these crazy
mistakes he doesn't have the sloppy
errors no I know I know that's not
exactly what you're saying but but in
terms of what we're going to vote for
ultimately like we've got a guy that
really has the package I think I agree
with you that there is a vulnerability
that maybe we should see a little bit
more a certain raw passion we should see
a little bit more and that's why I think
that moment that I just referenced was
was a good one I know I I actually I
actually think this is Ron has got to go
away I don't know how many times in my
life you want him to do Ayahuasca no not
Ayahuasca Ron if you're looking for a
foreign
but let me tell you A lot of times I
would say Jen I'll see you at dinner I'm
staying at the Four Seasons I gotta go
think and you would come into my room
and there was all these uh you know
these big papers that you write on but I
like the ones with the tape and the back
we can tip against the wall you would
come into my room and there's like 60 of
them against the wall
here's what I'm going to do with this
part with my Tico I'm going to do this
to raise them this way here's what my
plan is with villain this way here's
what I want to do with this company this
is what I want to do with this part of
my health I don't like my way wait I'm
at 258 can't stand it here's what I'm
going to do my marriage this is what I
want to do with God this is what I want
to do with my finances this is what I'm
going to do my investments and
everything is how to get there right but
the most important part when I did this
exercise and I got away from everybody
including my wife I don't want anything
you can get a hold of me the only person
that can get a hold of me is my wife I'm
in my room trust me call me I'm right
here right phone is off everything's
gone
I would go into sauna and I would sit
there and for two hours I'm in the sauna
jacuzzi all this stuff and I'm just
thinking what do you want to do next
what are you doing this for why do you
need to make the next move why do we
need to go to the next level you versus
upvd nobody exists this has to matter to
you why why why
every time
if I got to the moment where I'm
breaking down by myself I always came
out with better moves
this guy needs to take a break from
everybody
get away for two days it's not a long
time take a Saturday and a Sunday in
Jacksonville
get in a car you can't go to a hotel so
he's got to kind of figure out where to
go to a place that nobody came security
everybody can be outside you need to be
away from everybody and you need to have
a conversation with you
once I'm on a flight back from Chicago I
took a notepad and I wrote down why I'm
afraid of getting married and why I
don't want to get married I have that
paper till today I bring it back I put
in my Samsonite and I'm just writing
well because this happened is because of
this because of that because it is
because of that finally I'm like you
know what I'm good let's roll you're
going to get perfect but let's roll see
what happens with it okay I had to go
through that moment in a plane I'm like
sitting like this because I don't want
anybody to see me I don't think this is
a let's try to change Ron I don't think
this is a hey run you better say these
17 phrases I don't think this is you
know go give these 19th okay all that
stuff is the how-to I think the Y2 is
why do you give a so much
go back and say you're a good guy you're
doing the right things you ain't perfect
like this whole thing of walking on
Extras around yourself it's got to kind
of stop like go play ball and you may
lose all good or you may win all good
but the way you're going right now of
what you're doing I think you're going
back to being so afraid of what are
people going to say if I say this or
write this or do that and it's holding
you back anyways uh we can go to the
next I'll give you the final thoughts
here before we move away from
descendants no listen you're talking
about something existential something
ephemeral and and something that
captures that Zeitgeist thing that I
think is right you're you're doing like
a Jordan Peterson move on him that I
think probably would translate into
something that he wants which ultimately
is is to become president right to win
this thing and do it so I I actually
don't disagree with that I don't
disagree that and also it's just a
matter of I think we all have to accept
that you know we might sit here as
relatively functional people and be like
boy I just want the guy who's the best I
don't need all the magic tricks I don't
need all the viralness I don't need all
those things a certain amount of people
do a certain amount of people do whether
we like it or not so if that's a piece
that seems to be missing you're
obviously not the only person saying it
I I actually don't uh I actually do
agree with that fantastic well we're
going to go to the next topic I want to
show a couple of the clips of what
happened with Pence's last day of
running for office
but again guys we're about to announce
at the end of this year the first town
hall we're doing in this building
that'll happen on August 4th and the
tickets are going to sell out the moment
we especially the VIP ones we're going
to meet the candidate and going to back
with the cigar lines and this person's
actually wanting to go to the Cigar
Lounge and meet many of you text award
podcast to
310-340-1132 once again
310-340-1132 we'll send the link the
moment I announce it at the end of the
podcast so can you play this clip Taco
Carlson okay Tucker Carlson uh uh
conversation that's been coming up with
him on at I asked everybody at Turning
Point USA who went there and I'm asking
different guys to tell me who the stars
of the best messages they gave right who
are the stars
some say Obviously Trump
then they say Ronald uh uh uh what is
his name gentlemen Byron Byron oh Byron
Daniels no Donald Byron Donald yeah
crushed it right from Southwest forgive
me for not knowing his name is
he's a congressman from Fort Myers
how do you feel about it all the ladies
were waving you kisses he says that's
great but the only one that I'll receive
and kiss back is my wife he's a very
good he's Communicator he's got charm
seen him before I heard Trump I heard
Tucker I heard him I heard Kirk we're
the best speakers but a lot of people
said Tucker guns none of the show as
well
what I heard from a lot of people so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you
foreign